تحقيق لبيانات الجمارك الروسيه يكشف تقديم
الصين مساعدات عسكريه لروسيا مما تحتاجه
في الحرب باوكرانيا فما ابرز اوجه هذه
المساعدات
موسكو تزود مقاتلاتها وغواصاتها وجنودها
بمختلف الحاجيات بمساعدات الشركات الصينيه
صحيفه غول جورنال الامريكيه قالت ان
العمليه تتم من خلال تعويض جوانب النقص او
الخلل من التكنولوجيا ذات الاستخدام
المزدوج كاشباه الموصلات وهو امر ضروري
للحرب الحديثه اذ تمد الصين روسيا بمعدات
الملاحه والتشويش واجزاء الطائرات
المقاتله حيث قامت شركه صينيه مملوكه
للدوله بشحن قطع غيار للمقاتلات 35
النفاثه الى شركه روسيه مملوكه للحكومه
خاضعه للعقوبات بما قيمته مليار ومائه
مليون دولار فلوسيا ما تزال قادره على
استيراد تكنولوجيا رقائق الكمبيوتر
وكاميرات الاشعه تحت الحمراء ومعدات
الرادار من خلال دول لم تنضم الى الجهود
التي تقودها الولايات المتحده لعزل عن
الاسواق العالميه كتركيا وفق اول ستريت
جورنال الصحيفه حددت من السجلات اكثر من
12 شركه روسيه وصينيه استهدفتها الولايات
المتحده في اطار حمله الضغط على روسيا
بالاضافه الى جميع برامج العقوبات الاخرى
وقبل بدايه الحرب العام الماضي اعلن بوتين
وشي جين بينك شراكه بلا حدود بعد ذلك
حاولت تحقيق توازن حذر قائله انها تعارض
الحرب مع ابقاء علاقاتها الدبلوماسيه
والماليه والتجاريه مفتوحه مع روسيا بلال
البجداني العربيه